okay mulan boycotting the movie
that came out uh mario went and watched
it
and he said it's a phenomenal movie i
know mario's sitting there right now
saying don't watch it mario came insane
claimed he didn't watch it
he said it was insane so he loved it he
loved the movie he says the movie was
partially filed
in china this is the same i'm sorry
filmed in china
this is the same region where there are
there have been many human rights abuse
against millions of members of ethnic
muslim minority groups
main actor lou yeffi mulan
voiced support for hong kong police and
the chinese military government
police has been using violent force
against the hong kong protesters it is
suspected that
she is forced to back china's public
policies
where they free will uh or propaganda
statements okay
film actors and studio like jackie chan
are forced to promote pro-ccp values
this also creates issues for disney del
dorado uh this also creates issues for
disney so
you're hearing some of the stuff that's
going on with these guys that you're
making movies yet you're coming out
saying things about china you got to be
careful about what you're saying now
they're saying to boycott the movie
are you following the story adam at all
what's going on are you following anyone
what's going on i'm following
the bigger story here not so much the
mulan thing what's the bigger story the
bigger story is that in china which is a
obviously
communist country there's major human
right violations
major major and the center of that
is in the western region of china which
closely borders
pakistan and india and uh
you know there's uh bangladesh turkistan
or
tajikistan there's a lot of muslims in
that area and they call the uyghur
muslims spelled uh i think with a u
anyway
and they were full-on set up labor camps
concentration camps
where these people are forced to work
ironically
what they're saying is if you follow the
trail of this work
these people are forced into labor camps
and they've been making the face masks
uh that we've been wearing here in the
united states so the bigger story here
is that china
is just continually violating human
rights
um and uh it just these weaker muslims
and then
an offset of that is this this little
story with mulan and whatever they they
got going on it seems like a very china
thing to do to make an actress that's
going to star in the number one disney
movie when they don't even have theaters
open so you know how big this thing is
going to be
to make her force her to have these
statements 100 percent i believe
she was forced to what would she benefit
for commenting about the
about the hong kong police right so
absolutely china put
her up to this uh it makes it difficult
it's already a horrible year for disney
if you think about it you know how much
money they're losing on their theme
parks
30 million a day a day 30 million a day
and this
you know this the if you indirectly
support
china which kind of disney does because
they own espn which televises the nba
i mean and it's a slippery slope when
you
when you go after the general manager of
the houston rockets
for supporting the people of hong kong
right and you attack him
you know personally and almost cost him
to lose his job
you're on a very very slippery slope and
i just go back to this 100
that she was forced to make those
statements but um it's just making for a
more trying year for disney
and and uh questions they have to answer
that they never thought they'd have to
yeah because they thought this was going
to be the feel-good story the mulan
movie but
i'm gonna i'm gonna give you a
completely different perspective here so
uh yesterday when i'm talking to yuna
lee and she
was 24 years old when she left south
korea to come to the states
she wanted to go into film i said why
did you want to go into film
she says because i thought the biggest
impact i could make in the world is
through film
i was going to make film and tell
stories right and this is how it's going
to make impact because
a lot of times we are inspired by movies
we watch i grew up watching
cartoons in south korea about north
korea we saw them as all red pigs and
all this other stuff so
it influenced me as a kid i said okay so
she comes to the states goes eventually
and gets her uh
degree from columbia university which is
one of the best schools out there for
journalism and in that field that she
was going into i agree with her that one
of the biggest ways to change people's
thinking is through movies and film okay
when you think about titanic now
obviously we had this conversation
briefly yesterday together when you
think about titanic luis who do you
think about
when you think about titanic what do you
think about it you think about
leo leo dicaprio what do you think about
when you think about the movie uh
titanic you have never seen titanic
okay so what do you think about when you
think about the movie titanic
okay so so titanic when you think about
it you you you know most people think
about you know
you know she's standing king of the
world
oh my gosh i think a celine dion yeah a
great love story and all this other
stuff that you got between the two of
them okay great
you know the original titanic wasn't
starring you know dicaprio and all that
the original titanic the director and
the producers
and the funders of the original titanic
was
hitler's nazi regime
original titanic and by the way
the director of titanic when it first
came out in 1943
started speaking out against the nazi
regime
you know what happened to the guy he got
fired by who
hitler hitler was involved in the story
of the titanic sure he was more than
fire
right right well fired's got different
definitions but do you know do you know
who was the hero in the original titanic
probably some sort of nazi uh
a nazi soldier was the hero in the
original
exactly what is the moral the story what
i'm telling you right now is
chinese china is realizing the way
you impact the world on how they view
china
is through movies and cartoons and they
are brilliant they are
so brilliant and you got to watch them
very
very closely because there are so many
subliminal messages
that you are not going to catch so yes
so are you are you saying they're like a
big investor in disney so they can have
some
control a 100 okay i'm not even putting
it
90 percent 100 why
because china doesn't have the best
reputation around the world
so where do you start you have to start
either through movies
or music okay you can't really do music
right now okay because music is a
completely different game
you can do movies and cartoons and
what's the best age you can start
controlling people's minds
kids not older let me go and do that
with cartoons
so yes i do believe china's playing a
card like that and
you know with a lot of these cartoons
and things that are taking place you
gotta you gotta be very careful
my kids were watching cartoons and i'm
like babe what the hell was that right
there just what do you mean
i said okay guys get out of here go to
the other one real quick i want you to
watch this real quick maybe watch this
what does that look like to you she says
babe that's crazy
i said why the hell are they putting
this on netflix i'm not okay with this
cartoons that have subliminal messages
that you and i would catch what was it
i'm not going to talk about it but you
would catch you're like what the hell is
this all about
so the point is you got to be kind of
involved nowadays because if you don't
it's not even about sex and you know
[ __ ] and all this other stuff the
concern is isn't even about that
it's about who's the hero who's the hero
who's the hero you got to watch it very
very closely and you're seeing that
happening with movies right now
where a lot of the biggest hollywood
stars you tell a hollywood star
i'm gonna give you 40 million dollars
for a movie they'll do anything for you
you're going to give me 40 million
absolutely and we're going to make you
hero with 1.5 billion viewers
all we want you to say is nothing bad
about china oh dude don't worry about it
i'm good give me the 40.
simple here you go sign the contract
just say good things about us and say
most people don't understand their way
of living you have to understand who if
you've never lived
you have to understand that we have to
understand it we have to understand them
you know what you have to understand is
they're driven by power and they have a
vision made in 2025 made in china 2025
and they're pretty serious about it what
do you think is the end game for them do
they want to rule the world
they want power like you don't they want
to impose their way of thinking
on the world at what point does it turn
into military conflict do you think
is that part of their plan too well
they're not a military
uh although they're investing obviously
they double the nukes and all that other
stuff that they're doing they have to
get stronger on the military side
but their game is a different game and
they kind of gave us a flavor with the
last
five six months what happened uh uh in
march when we said shut down here yeah i
mean they're
the people people are one one day when
we watch this
and things come out like you know you
watch the movie argo and cia cannot
reveal all the stories for 30 years
that's a number you always hear about 30
years you can't know the real truth
well when you find that 30 years later
you don't emotionally care about it as
much as you do in the moment but when 30
years from now we find out what really
happened right now because someone's
going to come out
i mean you can't treat the people of
china the way you are right now for too
long
right social media is not helping these
guys out and these sanctions these
things that are going on right now this
guy gets re-elected trump gets
re-elected
china is hating life if trump gets
reelected
trump gets re-elected iran's hating life
china's hating life
and north korea is hating life because
north korea is backing against china so
you know china gradually the way they're
doing it is they're going through
regions that need money and countries
that need money and they're giving it to
them
and their last enemy they face is who
america
it's gonna be the last one you don't put
them in patience
and they're long-term thinkers they go
one by one by one by one by one and it's
okay
now that we have more than 50 percent of
the world that is on our side
now you better listen to us here's what
we expect we want you to add this into
your education we want you to add this
into your history books
we want you to have replace spanish with
chinese we want you to replace language
with this
we have to be very very careful with
what kind of influence these guys want
to have because
once they control media and tv and
movies you're kind of in trouble if that
takes place